6分
tee
re 所
me
[音楽]
[拍手]
ええええええ
[音楽]
[拍手]
わーりがとうございまーすすごいーっ
グラッチェ
ありがとうございますジャグリングパフォーマーの佐藤しています
覚えにくい方は
ポケットモンスターねポケモンのサトシで覚えたけどいっはっはっは
変や
今日はせっかくのペット博多ですか
皆さんに僕が
ジャグリングでへ世界いろんな人に称してきて
一つ思いついた面白いねー
アイデアをみなさんにシェアしたいと思います
ちょっとその前に深呼吸しましょうか
ついんですよ
いきましょうか信号機しましょう
深すぎますから大丈夫ですか
実は今日伝えたいことはこれなんです
僕少し前に1000人の前で性させて頂いた時がありました
その時に
お客さんが
その時は55カ国以上のお客さんがいました
頼りにしていた英語でさえ3割ぐらいの人しかわからないという状況でした
じゃあボディーランゲージを使おうと思ったんですけど
例えばじゃあちょっと手伝ってもらっていいですか
こうやったときに日本だと来てくださいって言うんですけど
アメリカとかだとこれはあっちに気になるんです
これはやばいぞと思った時に僕が使ったと唯一のね
人類共通の共通言語がありますそれは
呼吸です
明
僕はよくショーの中で呼吸を見せるのが大好きです
さっきみたいに
ええええええ
深呼吸しましょうって言うと
わかりますよね僕が息が上がっててとってもさっきのショーに集中していたということ
がわかります
そして皆さんはそれに共感してくれます
皆さんのために僕は一生懸命称しているってことが言葉を使わず伝わります
これがとっても便利なんですでこれはショボではそういう風に使いますけどもちろん
日常生活でどこでも使えます
例えばね挨拶のとき
今日ねああこんにちはどうもよろしくお願いします
っていう時とかあとはん
あとはー
うんわかったっていう感じです分かります今使いました
今の緊張感から緩和された感じ
を買った
っていう呼吸を相手に見せるんですそうすると相手に親近感がわきます
だって皆さん呼吸してますし
わかります
だからみんなで深呼吸をしようって言ったのはちょっと方でみんなで仲良くなりたいか
で僕の深呼吸に合わせさせました
それは僕とつながってほしいからです
だからこれを日常に使うには例えば子どもが
疲れて寝ちゃってる
よく聞いてください見ても分かります方とか胸とか見ても分かります
寝てます
で親とかね友達とかなんでもいいです隣でねそっと見守ってあげる人は一緒に呼吸を
合わせてあげましょう起きてますけどね
やるとはよりックスれますもしそれがものすごく甘くなると
こちら褒めてあげるんですそうすると
ピン甘な子供とかおきます
呼吸がずれただけで違和感は感じますえっ
例えば今使うんだったら
深呼吸しますよ
た入れないですよねこの感じわかります
例えば performa だと入場します入場して拍手が欲しい
その時にぽくが使うのは
ヘッドホン智ですどうぞ
みたいな感じです
この詰まっている間か皆さん耐えられないので動きたくなりませんちょっとこの
っていう感じが耐えられないなので皆さんが
できることといえば白書になるんです
なので言葉を使わずボディーランゲージもほとんど使わず
だけで拍手を取れると思う
それを日常生活に使ったりねどんどんしちゃってください
呼吸の使い方が詳しく分からない教えてくるということもいるんですけど
それは自分が知ってます自分の身体が知っています
リラックスしたい時に息を止めると言いません
力を入れたいときに向くっていうのは難しいです重い物を持ち上げる時に
うーん
っていうのはめちゃくちゃ難しいですってなりますよね
自分の方が知っていますその呼吸を大げさにするだけです
私はこういう呼吸をしているこういう人間なんですよっていう風に自分から線を下げて
あげてください
そうすると皆さんとつながって健吾もボディーランゲージは文化も出張も違っても
仲良くなることができ
ています
というところで最後はねぇ
僕のそういう呼吸を使った
とっても好きな音パフォーマンスを最後にお見せしたいと思います
これは
海外でしょうしたときに初めて言われました
あなたのショーはとても日本人的だと言われました
見てもわかるとおり別には服でもないし別にそう言う忍者とかでもないし
刀とかも使わないし演武も使いませんでも日本人的なと言われました
なぜならあなたのディーズ6店舗はとても独特
まがありますと
って日本の阿蘇考えて見たときに日本は
例えば水
水をししおどし
ってにまで楽しむエンターテインメントとして師匠としっていうの作ってますねこう
水をこう流すと一定時間でかターンてなるこれは水を痴漢の面白さに置き換えたんです
ね
西洋は噴水という見て左右対称美しい見てああすごい水のかたちという造形的な美しさ
に置き換えました
ただ日本はそういう時間まという名前をつけたり
時間と楽しむというところに結構秀でた文化なんじゃないかなと僕は思ってます
それが僕のショーに出ているという
そう言われましたなのでこの子をとっても好きです僕の
すごく日本人的な症
らしいです
ちょっと意図的に色々呼吸た金使ってやっていきます楽しんでくださいそれではやって
いきましょう
me
[音楽]
car
nao
[音楽]
衛兵 cal
ああああああ
ni
aname
[拍手]
heal いい
いえい
[拍手]
aal 2
[音楽]
[拍手]
me
ni
yeah
me
[音楽]
teao o
me
[音楽]
teame
yeah
いいいい
ええええええ
me
wh
dee
[音楽]
djebel
dea
[音楽]
info
can you do
ええええええ
me
uh
[拍手]
ええええええ
[音楽]
[拍手]
義母
goo
[音楽]
dare
me
[音楽]
わーをプラもーん
ありがとうございましょう分かっ